- How typical is it
for voters in this area
to see a Republican
candidate blockwalking?
MAYRA FLORES: Yeah, this
is new for them, it is.
It's probably the first
time in a long time
that they have a Republican
knocking their doors.
Prior to 2020, maybe people
weren't as confident in saying
that they were Republican.
But now, people
are confident and
they're not hiding it anymore.
- For decades, Republicans
wrote off the Rio Grande Valley
as a Democratic
stronghold, where
overwhelmingly Latino counties
stretch along the Texas border
with Mexico.
But that changed in 2020
when former President Donald
Trump made serious
gains here and stunned
the political world.
Now, Republicans are investing
in South Texas candidates,
including many of
Hispanic descent
from Congress to County judge.
MAYRA FLORES: This is what
the Republican looks like.
It isn't just about, you know,
for the rich or just white
people.
- Die hard fan right here.
MAYRA FLORES: You
follow his page?
Oh my God, can I give a hug?
- Yes.
MAYRA FLORES: How old are you?
- 16, in March I'll be 17.
MAYRA FLORES: Wow, really.
- Yes, just one more
year and I can vote.
MAYRA FLORES: This
area has been voting
Democrat for over 100 years.
I feel we've been
taken for granted,
we've been loyal to a party
that has done absolutely nothing
for us.
We have families in Mexico
that we are not visiting
anymore because we're afraid.
So we don't want what
we're afraid to come here.
- Republican frontrunner and
first time candidate Mayra
Flores is running in
a four-way primary
in one of three
top congressional
races in South Texas.
Both the 15th and the 34th
districts are newly redrawn.
And sitting Congressman
Vincente Gonzalez
has switched from the 15th,
which became more favorable
to Republicans, to
run in the 34th,
now more favorable
to Democrats where
he will likely face Flores.
VINCENTE GONZALEZ:
All the benefits
I've had in my
lifetime were created
by the Democratic party.
And I think most people in
my region feel the same.
- Monica De La Cruz
is a second time
Republican candidate,
running for the now
open seat in the 15th district.
In 2020, she came close
to ousting Gonzalez,
the Democratic incumbent here.
MONICA DE LA CRUZ:
Socialists are
ruining our border security,
our values, and our economy.
- De La Cruz was
endorsed by Trump
and has echoed some of his
false claims about voter fraud.
But her central
focus is immigration.
MONICA DE LA CRUZ:
President Trump
cared about the border, cared
about border patrol agents
and law enforcement agents.
So in the 2020 election,
people got motivated,
were engaged, and
worked to win this seat.
And we came within three
points of doing so.
When I ran, people
said, you're crazy,
this is a Democrat stronghold,
you don't have a chance.
- Democrats in South
Texas say the claims
that their party has forgotten
Latino voters are fiction,
and that Latino
voters were still
a key part of Biden's
support in major Metropolitan
areas of Texas in 2020.
They argue that the party
lost some Latino support
in the border counties
because it largely
suspended in-person
campaigning during the pandemic
and must do a better job
of connecting with voters
on issues like the
border and the future
of the oil and gas industry,
which fuels many jobs here.
MICHELLE VALLEJO: Unfortunately,
the previous administration
showed up to use our
border wall as a photo op.
And it worked because
it ended up on the TV.
Approaching the border and
immigration conversation
in that way is
divisive, and it takes
away from the
actual conversation
we should be having.
- Democrats who have long had
a diverse slate of candidates
in South Texas are confident
they can reverse GOP momentum
here in 2002 now that they are
back campaigning intensively
in these communities.
Both sides have long
acknowledged that the Latino
vote is not a monolith.
The November election will test
whether the GOP can maintain
the gains they made among
Latino voters in key states,
when Trump is not on the ballot.
MAYRA FLORES: We
are the forgotten,
and Bronzeville has
been the forgotten.
I am not here to represent
a political party,
I'm here to represent you.